There's a work out of Stanford and
UC Berkeley
on using reinforcement learning to
actually fly model helicopter tricks.
>> Like what?
>> So it turns out that if you,
you're flying a model helicopter,
I've tried to do this.
Turns out to be really hard to do.
Part of it is you have to coordinate
the blades in the blades in the Blades.
>> Yeah, and part of it is that you
can do crazy things with helicopters,
if you know how to do it.
You can make them fly upside down,
you can make them swing back and
forth, you can make them kind
of roll over and over and over.
You can do all sorts of really,
well I don't know,
you can do all sorts of amazing things,
but
professional stunt flying helicopter
people can do amazing things.
What the reinforcement learning work was
about is trying to get a system to learn
to do those same kinds of tricks.
>> And they were able to do
this with real helicopters or
real model helicopters?
>> A real model helicopter,
not a simulator, but
an actual Mini helicopter.
>> Okay, so that's cool.
So you sort of convinced me that burlap
and repository, that's sort of a good.
Okay, I buy that.
But I do want to point out
something that you said,
that I thought was interesting.
You talked about simulators and
that maybe what we really want to
do is work in the real world.
But it occurs to me that at
least one of those examples,
the simulator is the real world.
So, games, right?
So if you have games like Backgammon,
if you have simulations that
people actually interact with
then that is actually the real problem
itself, that is the real world.
But if I'm playing Pac-Man and
I've got a simulator for Pac-Man,
that's the same thing as having Pac-Man.
And if I can learn to play Pac-Man,
I've learn to play Pac-Man.
There's not really a simulator involved.
>> I would make a distinction between
grid world type simulators where
they were developed specifically for
reinforcement learning
researchers to work with.
Versus, as you say, the kinds of
simulators that people actually interact
with when they're doing things
like playing video games.
>> And so, video games actually is
a really great intermediate step between
real physical world stuff and
things that can be run in simulation.
And actually there's been some
terrific work in that space.
>> Really, like what?
>> Well, one of the things that
I'm very excited about recently is
a group called Deep Mind, which
they're very good at naming things.
Have a system for
actually doing what they call deep
reinforcement learning, deep q learning.
Where they are actually trying to
learn behavior in Atari video games.
Video games from the 80s, where they
actually are using Atari emulators,
the actual games as people
actually play them.
Taking the information that's
available on the screen as input and
sending joystick commands as output, and
learning to play actually at
the level of human players.
>> Wait,
they're as good as human players?
>> They are as good on
average as human players.
In some of the games, they're
actually much better than people.
Games like Breakout where you
have to bounce a ball all around.
>> Okay.
>> And
then there's other games where they're
actually much much worse than people.
Games like Frost Bite where you have
to jump around on a bunch of ice floes.
It seems very difficult for
the system to actually learn
what to do in that game.
>> Okay, so their heads in an oven,
their feet is in ice water.
But on average, they're comfortable.
>> I see what you're saying.
So, your point is that it's not
playing just like a person.
It's playing better and
worse than people, so
on average you can say that it's
kind of playing like people.
>> Mm-hm, but still that's kind of cool.
>> I think it's really amazing and
I think it's that particular data set
is itself really interesting, because
there's 40 some odd Atari video games
that are all built in the same system.
You can use the same inputs, and
the same outputs, and the same learning
algorithm, but you can put in different
games to see what it will do.
>> Okay, so it is just like Weka and
it's just like UCI, except here,
Weka is the burlap algorithms or
whatever, reinforcement algorithms.
And UCI, instead of being input output
pairs are sort of the real world.
>> Yeah, and there's some work that's
being done in collecting data from
the real world.
For example, medical diagnosis or
online education.
>> I like that,
we should do something like that.
>> [LAUGH] For
trying to figure out what the right way
of interacting with people online is.
People have collected some of that data
and there's reinforcement learning
algorithms that are being
run at that data.
It's not the full reinforcement learning
problem, because you don't actually,
the learning system doesn't actually
have to decide how to collect the data,
it's already been collected for it.
But it is really using real data and
making decisions based on that and
I think that's a really
promising direction for
reinforcement learning
to go in the future.
>> Okay, I like it.
So I got two things out of that.
The first thing is reinforcement
learning really can be used in the real
world, it has been, it can be and
there's a nice bright future for
it that's good.
And the second thing is I was right,
there was a bunch of stuff
we hadn't talked about.
>> Yeah, okay, all right,
that's a valid point.
>> Okay, was there anything else
you want to wrap up with anything?
>> Well, I feel like we should say maybe
a little bit about the current direction
in the future of reinforcement learning.
So, one of the things I think is really
neat is that it's having an impact
not just on engineering and
computer science, but
also on the behavioral sciences and
the neurosciences.
>> How so?
>> Well so, the sorts of things that we
think about reinforcement learning being
good for, are an agent it's
interacting with some environment,
it's making decisions.
It's trying to figure out what to do,
it's trying to be happy.
And so you could argue that animals and
people are trying to do exactly those
sorts of things,
that we are reinforcement learners.
>> Sure animals do it, people do it.
>> Yeah.
>> Birds do it.
>> Educated fleas have been known
to do reinforcement learning.
>> Right, okay.
>> And so, the interesting thing about
that is the Nora scientists when they're
trying to think about, okay.
Well, how can we understand the
algorithms that essentially that people
are running.
They're turning to the reinforcement
learning field as a source of
inspiration for the structure of
the algorithm, how they can be set up.
What sorts of things seem to work and
not work and they're actually looking
for evidence of these in real brain.
>> I like that.
I like that a lot.
And you know what I
really like about that?
That it takes us back to the beginning
of the machine learning class.
It takes us back to the beginning of
the reinforcement learning class,
where we tried to emphasize the point
that reinforcement learning
is not just a set of algorithms,
it's not just an approach.
It's actually a way of
thinking about problems.
And so really this whole class
has been about solving problems.
And I feel like we have
solved some problems.
>> Great, I think that's
a wonderful note to end things on,
what do you think?
>> No, I think this is really valuable,
thanks so much.
>> All right well,
thank you very much, Michael.
I appreciate it and
I will see you in the next class.
Bye.